hello everyone welcome to the highlight
show of class chess international my
name is sara barba Hammond and I'm going
to take you to key moments of day one
the tournament is being sponsored by San
Luis chess club and will take place from
June 6 to 14 it will involve the eight
players you see below who will be
fighting it out for $265,000 prize fund
if you're unfamiliar with the cloud
format the reason it's called cloud
chess is because there are certain games
where a win is worth more and of witness
also worth $2,000 so I will explain it
as we go along so today was day 1 of
quarterfinals so we had a very exciting
day of two matches Magnus Carlsen versus
chef pressure and Maxima chair lagravis
Wesley so so let's take a look at what
happened in those matches so let's start
with the match between Magnus Carlsen
and Geoffrey Zhang so this was a very
tough match for a young 19 year old
American because he lost his first three
games in a row so let's take a look at
the key moments in those games so in the
first game Geoffrey was actually up a
piece but the game was very up and down
and both players had their chances so
the final mistake came on move 34 so
let's see what happened right before so
we're at move 33 so Queen B someone was
played and here Geoffrey blundered with
Bishop g4 and the reason this is a
blunder is because black has the and the
reason this is a blunder is because
White has this move
Quinn v8 taking advantage of the back
rank Queen f8 and now Knight f6 winning
the piece back so there's still some
fight left in the game so let's take a
quick look at what happened
and I will show you another key moment
in this game so d5 limiting the night
the King is running to take that pawn so
wide decides to part ways with a pawn
and sticks instead takes that this
exponent goes for the King side pawns
so Knight goes 3 6 and now Magnus is
pushing he is h-bond defending the
knight so Geoffrey decides to create his
own counter play so takes rook b1 so now
rook the 8 is impossible because after
take and Queen
there's rock h1 check winning the Queen
back so instead Magnus plays g5 and a g3
and now young Geoffrey blunders with
night at 4 because after King g4 rook g8
simply winning the night and the rook
the black rook cannot move with a check
so after rook h1 rugby six white is
going to be up a full piece so that was
Gaiden 1 let's move on to our next game
between the two so let's go to the key
moment on move 65 so a lot of things
happen in this game but we don't the
game was very long and we want to just
cover the key moments so in this
position white goes King g3 giving up
the pawn on e4 so the pan was already
impossible to defend so he decides to go
after the Japan and here we're here is
where Jeffrey makes his crucial mistake
going King before instead of running his
King to the Queen side trying to stop
this pawn instead he goes after the
Japan but unfortunately he's not in time
because after 95 Pepsi to 93 check so of
course impossible to take the knight
because under a pond will Queen the palm
runs to a 4 and here Geoffrey resides
because it's impossible to stop this
pawn because for example if there should
be 1 we can just play a 3 so white is
just simply not in time
if the bishop runs somewhere then Knight
B 3 and this part pawn is too far from
queening and this fund already Queen's
in two moves so really tough start for a
tough start for a young America but
let's take a look at what happened in
Game three
so game 3 was considered masterpiece by
yes sir Sailor man who had a lot of
praise for Magnus Carlsen for the way he
handled this game so let's start on move
21 so as we can see in this position
already a White has quite a strong
attack with the dark squares on the
and all these pieces here and the pond
storm and this rope that eventually can
go to each one to join the attack so
each wife was playin so 95 was played
attacking the f7 pawn rook e7 bringing
the rook into the center a lift rook
threatening Brooke after a rock h3h 5
it's very hard to suggest good news for
Geoffrey
so exchanging the routes and now 9 8 7
the final blow in the position and
blacks positions are simply falling
apart
so after takes Bishop g5 threatening to
take the rook let's say if we make some
if I just pass the move for black
somehow just to show you the threat now
hanging this bishop so instead after
Bishop g5 the King went back but now
after take take White has another
possibility of playing Roxy 1 and now
the rook is joining the attack so Queen
went to before rook c8 h6 and it's going
to be very difficult to defend this
position so the threat was all ready to
play h7 and took on f7 which he did
anyways so queening the palm and takes
the pawn on f7 so Geoffrey decides to
take the pawn on d4 looking for some
kind of counter play but unfortunately
he's now going to be losing every single
pawn with a check so he loses this pawn
he loses the e6 pawn which in turn
defense upon on g4 so after a couple
more moves he simply resigned because
after Queen f7 this pawn is just
quitting so three in a row was a really
rough start for the youngster but there
was still a lot of chess to be played
three more games to go and the class
games were ahead so in this game in
Magnus Carlsen had the black pieces in
Game four of the match and looks like
Geoffrey is not doing very well with the
opposite color bishops but here for some
reason after taking the pawn Magnus
decided to go rookie two and the game
eventually appeared adding to a drop but
instead he had a better try of playing
g4 I'm trying to keep some kind of an
attack going because h4 can always
my g3 which is really nasty and white
doesn't really want to allow this giving
up the H file we're allowing black to
build a very strong attack and it's very
hard for white intern to access this
King because this King is a lot safer
than the g1 King but instead as I
mentioned he played rookie tune and
after some more exchanges and trading
queens there was some still some fight
left in the position but eventually
Jeffery managed to draw the game so it
was very important for him to stop
bleeding
and to get back on the scoreboard with
half a point so up next were the two
clutch game said the reason this is
called class chess is because of this
clutch games where each win is worth two
points and the DRI is one point so of
course this gives an opportunity to the
player who's struggling to bounce back
with a couple of wins and either catch
up or leapfrog their opponent so for
example had Geoffrey won both of this
games he would have lived frag his
opponent and taken a late in the match
and that's exactly what he did in the
game once so let's take a look at the
key point in game 1 of class chess of
clutch games so let's go straight to the
key point of the game so Geoffrey Jean
with the black pieces very impressively
wins a pawn against the world champion
and successfully wins the game
so b5 so let's take a look at this
Bishop and game a g6 with the idea of
playing h5 to create a passed pawn
bringing the king to stop this pawn
bishop before of course you cannot touch
the bishop because the pond will Quinn
so Bishop on that goes back and now
pushing the pawn on h5 and it's very
difficult to deal with passed pawns on
the other side opposite sides of the
port because pieces cannot do so much
they cannot control so many squares for
example this King cannot stop both of
these pawns so after taking the bishop
goes back Jeffery pushes King c6
impossible to take the pawn
because the to simply Queens so magnets
goes kingi form because if King h4 then
simply Bishop f4 and if white tries to
make a drug he's simply not on time and
you cannot attack the pawn next move
black can just play f6 and just simply
win the game with extra piece
so instead King g4 but now Bishop g3 and
again cannot take on g3 cannot win this
fun and like is going to be out to pants
and he will convert this fight easily so
big results for the American youngster
yes we're beating the world champion
with the black pieces so finally there
was one more game left between these two
players the final clutch game had
Geoffrey won this game he would have
scored four and a half points and
laphroaig his opponent and actually had
some good winning chances but things
didn't quite go his way his wife so as
you can see it actually the final
position ended up king versus King so
let's jump to key moment in this game so
in this position rich be one is played
you should be for King goes back check
and here we're here is where Geoffrey
made a mistake we're taking only five
instead he could have played Bishop c5
and rook t1 threatening this really
annoying check of Bishop d6 and it's
impossible to take this rook and now
actually it's really hard to find a good
square for the knight cannot go to e7 if
you go to d6 you're losing a bishop at
the very least and if you go Knight a5
let me push the pawn if the King goes
back we push the pawn one more time
winning the piece so actually after
Bishop c5 rule t7 rook t1 blacks best
chance is to take on f4 give up the
exchange and fight in this position but
of course white is the one in the
driver's seat so a big missed
opportunity for Geoffrey shank and but
he felt very good about the second half
of the tournament rightfully so and
Magnus himself said that he was getting
tired while his opponent started playing
better so we will see what how this
match will end actually tomorrow there
be a series of different matches will
mention later and this match will resume
on Monday so let's go back to our Maxine
Maxine virtual lock reverse is Wesley so
match so Wesa was actually the winner of
the first edition of class jessie
diffident Fabiana karana in the finals
so it's actually quite familiar with
this format so let's take a look in the
first game so this was great preparation
by Wesley so but unfortunately he was
not able to convert so let's go to move
16 after castle's rook f1 I think they
have 7 pawn bishop h4 g3 just ignoring
this check and simply taking the pawn
and castle Inc and as we can see blacks
position is just awful this King is
going to become a very problematic piece
so Queen comes into the game g6 plan is
falling takes the pawn and queen is 7
rock age 4 so simple mate threat there's
no time to take this pawn it does for
example if you take this is going to be
checkmate so instead Maxima Telegraph
decides to take the rook on h4 but now
he's unfortunately down the queen yeah
he does have a rook on a night so a few
moves later something really shocking
happens in this position Wesley so plays
queen b7 blundering 96 and the
unfortunate thing is the Queen can not
go anywhere to attack this roki not go
to d7 cannot go to f7 cannot go to c6
cannot go to b5 all the squares are
covered so because there's no way to
attack this rook and district of also as
untouchable he has to go for this line
but there was still a lot of fight in
this game but it eventually ended up in
a draw so let's move on to our next game
this is the opposite of the Magnus
versus Jeffrey match because this match
started with 3 draws but in every game
Western saw was the one with the chances
so eventually he did manage to win a few
games so let's go to our next game
which also ended in a drop so this game
a lot of key points but what I wanted to
show you is the ending of this game and
this is something every chess player
should know how to hold this kind of an
endgame
so rook b8 so Wesley so with the black
pieces again some had some winning
chances but eventually win that industry
game so a for c5 King come here King
comes closer and the problem for white
is this King is just too far away from
the action now check a couple of checks
later and this is the key part playing
rugby 3 so I hope all of you who are
watching this you're familiar with this
defense it calls it called the banker a
defense so the key is when I can come
closer the rook stays on the side and as
the King gets closer to the punt he's
checking the King from the side and then
when the King attacks the rope you swing
the rope to the other side if the pawn
ever pushes simply put the rook behind
go all the way back and you can just
wait back and forth on these squares so
every chess player should really know
this endgame
so King g4 was played again checking
from the side and the game ended in a
draw the players agree to a drought
knowing that this is a well known and
game unless he knows how to hold it so
let's take a look on game 3
okay so let's start with this position
so this was also I think some kind of a
preparation because as we see both the
players ended the game with more clock
so I think this was kind of some kind of
a preparation because as we can see the
players ended the game with more time on
their clock so even though I couldn't
find any games in the database I think
this was some kind of home preparation
for both of them and Max him actually
played the samisen max him actually
played the slab in both games and we're
used to seeing the groom felt from him
there was some kind of a switch from him
so I don't know if this is something we
should expect in the candidates or not
but in this particular tournament he has
been playing different opening so Bishop
c3 was played before sacrificing
the bishop Queen a for Queen escapes
there should be five another crazy move
Knight f6
and this is a very bizarre repetition so
I think when you play something like
this with wider kind of hope your
opponent doesn't know it because you
start the bell objectively the best move
for both sides if both players play the
objectively pass moves very the game
ends in a draw and the game ends in a
really funny
repetition so this were have first three
games which ended in a trap but in every
game as you can see west leader have a
good preparation or here the big edge so
you know eventually when you're
constantly in a bad position at some
point you do crack and that is what
happened in the next game so let's take
a look at how it happened in game forces
so this is the final game between the
clutch game so each win still counts as
one point and after having so many good
positions in the first three game well
so does finally win a game because
that's what happens when you're
constantly in a bad position at some
point you cry because it's very
difficult mentally to just defend in
every game so let's jump back to so
let's jump to our key moment of the
round so as you can see and just take a
second to digest what's going in this
position to this position is absolutely
crazy
black did take a rock on a1 but
obviously this Knight is trapped and
even and at this point why decides to
just go after this Knights and get it so
taking it immediately doesn't work
because check and take on b5 so instead
Bishop e2 is plate which is actually a
mistake for really remarkable reason so
Wesley finds this amazing resource in
the position brilliant move rook t3 so
the idea is to attack this Knight
indirectly by cutting off this defense
so after taking now we also created a
square for our night and night we'll
actually once the night lands on c2 it
will cut it will capture the pawn on a
tree so root K 1 was played and if you
try a 97 actually it's nice trapped
so it's impossible to get this night out
so after in that table should be five
tonight we'll go to see tune and at some
point C four will be played to keep the
king escapes we can take it and the
night will escape so actually a pretty
funny position with both of the night
strapped in trapped because the see
tonight cannot move the c7 Knight cannot
move but instead maxim decides to take
and we end up in this and then we
eventually found ourselves in this
opposite color Bishop endgame but
because they are rooks present and
because black is up upon and this is
very poor structure in White's position
these two passed pawns position the
position is actually very tough to hold
so we should determine or clipped very
nice maneuver and after exchanging let's
see how Maxie and so let's see how
West's all wins this game so pushing the
pants and there is a nice entryway for
the King so the King just gets into the
position defending the pawn and after
bringing the King to the other side of
the board eight six okay after d5 takes
takes it takes d5 actually Maxie and ran
out of time and black won the game so
this was the first big victory by Wesley
so who now is a point ahead so up next
are the two clutch Kings where each win
is worth two points and a draw is one
point so let's take a look at those two
games so if we take a look at this
position white has really nice expansion
in the center so he plays a for Maxim
goes b5 takes tanks and keeps expanding
and after g4 before we realize that this
is where Bishop is in trouble
and why it is simply trying to trap it
if you take the bishop is chopped
so instead I five is played exchanging
the dark square Bishop sand we will see
the very good technique by the American
player going C 4 T 5 T 6 distracting the
rook taking this pawn penetrating on the
7 rank stopping any kind of threats with
on the second rank taking the pawn and
the rest is just a matter of very good
technique rook c7 creating a meeting net
so the King runs back still in a meeting
net by the way about the right of
meeting too so check and here resents
because there are a lot of ways to win
we can't consider taking on c6 going
into the opponent game or just simply
coming here and just going after the
sponsons just winning them so just a
hopeless position for like so there's no
reason to continue and with this way now
Wesley so has three three point lead
over his opponent because the wind was
worth two points and let's take a look
in the final game Wesley so with the
black pieces let's jump to our key
moment in this game so we reached this
room so in this game actually maximum
showed amazing resilience to fight back
and make a drop because as we can see he
is down upon and black does have this
too connected passed pawns but
thankfully his King is stopping and the
pants and this King is not very active
so here maximum finds a great resource
of a5 breaking apart blocks pawn
structure and starting to take pawns so
now the material is equal and white
himself has this past month so now he
has better chances to make a drum King
gauge 3 and now black is the one who
decides to give up this pawn and go
after this one
and the game ends in a draw quite
quickly as all the pieces get exchanged
and web King and King King versus King
so they want of quarterfinals and it
with Magnus Carlsen with a point lead
over his opponent and Wesley so a three
point lead over his opponent so both
places so and Geoffrey Zhang actually
went to thousand dollars extra for
winning clutch games so this matches are
going to resume on Monday tomorrow we're
going to have a very exciting take as
we're going to have Levon Aronian versus
Alexander Christian Fabiano Quranic
verses linear at Dominguez so make sure
you're checking out those games on us
Geoff stamps.com or on st. Louis chess
club's YouTube channel there's going to
be live coverage but yes Jan and Maria
starting at 1 p.m. central see you then